if I have a radioactive isotope and I
say it has a half-life of a year what
that means is that after a year there's
a 50% chance that the decays or a 50%
chance it doesn't decay and if I have a
million isotopes after year
sure enough I'll have half a million
however I can't I don't know which half
will have decayed until the year is up
but I can't predict accurately that
roughly half of them will go well
Schrodinger said well what about if I
had not a million isotopes but one
isotope let's say it has a half-life of
an hour if it decays it will emit an
alpha particle that alpha particle will
break over in a bottle of poison gas and
the poison gas could kill a cat that we
put inside a box it's not like that we
physicists hate cats
but you may argue that the process of
observing the radioactive isotope
changes whether it decays or doesn't
decay but few people would say looking
at a cat changes whether it's alive or
dead so it's a way of amplifying a
microscopic event to something
macroscopic you put the cat in the box
you close the lid after an hour you open
it up quantum mechanics says that
there's a 50% chance that the isotope
has decayed in which case the it's
emitted a particle and the cat has died
but a 50% chance it doesn't decay in
which case we would find a live cat
until you open the box the only way to
describe the cat is an average of half
alive and half dead that sounds so
stupid that we use different language
there's a linear superposition of two
orthogonal quantum states but basically
it's saying to camp alive half dead and
then when you open up the box the
wavefunction collapses into either one
situation all alive or another situation
all dead as strange as this sounds
recent experiments in bobbing entangle
quantum states seem to suggest that this
is in fact what happens but in 1957 Hugh
Everett the third as part of his PhD
thesis at Princeton proposed an
alternative explanation he said there
was no average of half alive half dead
no collapsing wave functions what
happened was that
we closed up the box initially we split
off two parallel universes and at the
end of the hour the the wave functions
don't collapse all we do is discover do
we live in the universe where the cat
lived or the universe where the cat died
and for every quantum event there's at
least two other that has two outcomes
there's at least that many different
universes so there was in principle an
infinite number of parallel universes
needless to say physicists did not
consider this helpful and these these
ideas which have been later on described
by Bryce tu-whit as the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics have
been considered kind of like the crazy
aunt of quantum theory and ignored up
until fairly recently but string
theorists and other physicists trying to
develop a quantum theory of gravity have
found that they needed to dust off this
many-worlds interpretation and apply it
to their theories in order to make them
work out